it's hard to keep up with who said what
in which Senate or House panel hearing
about Russia lately since there have
been so many but I'll remind you about
one assertion that was made that turns
out to not be true last week now fired
FBI director James Comey
said during a Senate committee hearing
which we covered that quote hundreds and
thousands of emails containing
classified information were forwarded
from Hillary Clinton's aide Yuma Abbadon
to the home computer she shared with her
I call him her outgoing husband Anthony
Weiner this was part of why the Huma
Abedin Anthony Weiner aspect of the
story was huge in terms of the Hillary
Clinton email investigation hundreds and
thousands of classified emails
that's huge we need to look into that
right here's James Comey last week I
said to my team were got to walk into
the world a really bad I've got to tell
Congress that we're restarting this not
in some frivolous way in a hugely
significant way and the team also told
me we cannot finish this work before the
election and then they worked night
after night after night and they found
thousands of new emails they found
classified information on Anthony Weiner
somehow her emails are being forwarded
to Anthony Weiner including classified
information by her assistant Huma Abedin
and so they found thousands of new
emails and then called me the Saturday
night before the election and said
thanks to the wizardry of our technology
we've only had to personally read six
thousand we think we can finish tomorrow
morning Sunday it turns out that James
Comey not slightly but drastically
overstated the number of emails in
question and that none of the emails
were classified at the time was missing
altogether from James commis statement
there some of the emails in question
have since been classified but that's a
very different scenario than saying that
there were just endless classified
emails forwarded again the emails were
not classified at the time some of the
information contained within has since
been classified why did he do this it's
not clear it's again not just the number
of emails but this issue of whether they
were classified or not and Abaddon did
occasionally forward emails to her house
than for printing but it was not the
number described by Comey
it was not a regular practice and again
none of those emails were marked
classified this was one of the headlines
among right-wing media after commis
testimony and it turns out to have been
false and it's hard to say whether or
not he lied because to prove someone
lied means you have to find out that
they knew better and deliberately tried
to mislead the public no doubt so maybe
he just misspoke or was mistaken but on
an issue that's this important you got
to get that right if you believe James
Comey botched the public side of the
Clinton email and Trump Russia
investigations choosing to mention only
one of those investigations prior to the
November 8 election this only adds to
those concerns if you believe that it
was not logical for James Comey to go
public about the Clinton investigation
but not go public about the Trump
investigation prior to November 8th the
fact that the case around the Clinton
emails is even weaker than we thought as
revealed by these recent statements
those concerns only grow this calls into
question James Comey supposed position
as a nonpartisan investigator of all
that comes before him things are getting
no better for James Comey he since been
fired but again miss statements with
regard to the broader defense of why he
did what he did with the Hillary Clinton
email investigation and of course this
story came out only a few hours before
James Comey was fired yes leads you to
believe that this was the impetus for
his firing and they wanted to do it all
along yeah well when you look at Trump's
claims right again and we're not going
to redo the Trump fired call me thing
but from the story at the beginning of
the show
Trump's letter says that it's because of
the handling of the Hillary Clinton
email investigation that he ultimately
fired Comey every indication is that
they've been looking to fire Comey for a
while but at the time nothing has really
changed with regard to the Clinton
investigation so why didn't they fire
him on January 20th when Donald Trump
could have and everything there points
to just desperation wanting to separate
Comey from the Trump Russia
investigation it's hard to believe that
this was the last straw on the very
Clinton email investigation in
particular that I think is a good way to
sort of say it and bottom line it was
bad judgment at best and corruption at
worst to go public with only the Clinton
investigation prior to November 8th it's
now all falling apart and
becoming clear that that aspect was a
major blunder by Comey but it is totally
it totally lacks credibility to believe
that that's why Donald Trump ultimately
made the decision to fire James Comey